Katrina: 敲不醒了
Katrina: Can't wake him up.
Jake:敲不醒
Jake: Can't wake him up.
Katrina: 真的假的
Katrina: Really?
Jake:他露西敲不醒
Jake: Lucia can't be woken up.
Jake:他醒了以前都是他醒不了
Jake: He woke up before, but now he can't.
Jake:每人都有醒不了的时刻
Jake: Everyone has moments when they can't wake up.
Katrina: 居然
Katrina: Wow.
Jake:人均醒不了
Jake: It's common.
Katrina: 你刚洗了吗
Katrina: Did you just shower?
Shure: 有一点
Shure: A little bit.
Jake:有一点有点粉
Jake: Yeah, a little bit.
Katrina: 啥意思你拿我那个洗啦
Katrina: What do you mean, did you use my stuff?
Shure: 有点紫
Shure: A bit purple.
Katrina: 没啥子
Katrina: No big deal.
Jake:有一种这个粉色的感觉
Jake: It has a bit of a pink feel to it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈你还是就是
Katrina: Haha, you still...
Katrina: 这这这是确实粉紫色的
Katrina: Yeah, it's definitely pinkish-purple.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 雨轩现在要不帮忙叫一下吧
Shure: How about you call Yuxuan?
Jake:感觉到了
Jake: I can feel it.
Katrina: 全是紫色的
Katrina: It's all purple.
Shure: 帮忙叫一下
Shure: Help call him.
Shure: 都鸭嗓子了
Shure: My voice is hoarse.
Jake:来两位帮忙帮个忙吧
Jake: Come on, you two, lend a hand.
Katrina: 染吧染个那种骚骚粉
Katrina: Dye it, dye it that flashy pink.
Shure: 你要不私闯进去
Shure: Why don't you just barge in?
Jake:弹了给个背景音
Jake: Play some background music.
Katrina: 不在
Katrina: Not here.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:在外边吗难道
Jake: Outside, maybe?
Jake:哎呀哎呀
Jake: Oh no, oh no.
Katrina: 哎呀哎呀
Katrina: Oh no, oh no.
Katrina: 瞎吧
Katrina: Blind?
Shure: 我寻思得睡多死啊
Shure: I think you need to sleep like the dead.
Katrina: 哈哈哈笑死
Katrina: Haha, that's hilarious.
Katrina: 哇这里还有阳光玫
Katrina: Wow, there's sunlight here.
Jake:在还是不在啊
Jake: Here or not?
Katrina: 不在啊
Katrina: Not here.
Jake:不在啊
Jake: Not here.
Katrina: 床上没有人啊
Katrina: No one on the bed.
Katrina: 偶买噶增加一点悬疑的情节唉
Katrina: Oh my god, add a bit of suspense!
Katrina: 哎呀忘记关空调了
Katrina: Oh no, I forgot to turn off the air conditioner.
Katrina: 小瓶子
Katrina: Little bottle.
Jake:是在这吗
Jake: Is it here?
Jake:是在厕所吗
Jake: Is it in the bathroom?
Jake:会吗
Jake: Could it be?
Katrina: 厕所他也会回答我们呀
Katrina: Would he answer us from the bathroom?
Jake:那应该得听见是吧
Jake: Then we should hear him, right?
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 我擦一下我的眼镜
Katrina: Let me wipe my glasses.
Katrina: 哈哈这一唱太有性缩力了
Katrina: Haha, this singing is too seductive.
Katrina: 我的天
Katrina: Oh my god.
Katrina: 性张力的反义
Katrina: The opposite of sexual tension.
Katrina: 不见了吗露亚
Katrina: Did Lucia disappear?
Jake:他去卫生所了
Jake: She went to the clinic.
Katrina: 怎么了不舒服啊
Katrina: What's wrong? Is she not feeling well?
Jake:他呃去玩狗的时候被狗抓了一下
Jake: She got scratched by a dog while playing with it.
Jake:他不放心
Jake: She was worried.
Jake:打疫苗去了
Jake: So she's getting vaccinated.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:白敲啦
Jake: It's a waste of effort.
Katrina: 去哪打了呀
Katrina: Where did she go for the shot?
Jake:就附近的一个卫生所
Jake: Just to a nearby clinic.
Katrina: 你要等他回吗
Katrina: Are you going to wait for her to come back?
Jake:不用了
Jake: No need.
Katrina: 直接我们讨论
Katrina: Let's just discuss it ourselves.
Jake:对直接讨论
Jake: Yeah, let's just discuss.
Katrina: OK啊开始吧
Katrina: Okay, let's start.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:唉还有一个人没选会没出来了
Jake: Hey, there's still one person who hasn't chosen and hasn't come out.
Katrina: 破门而入
Katrina: Break in!
Shure: Natasha
Shure: Natasha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 乌日啦mother rush
Shure: Urila mother rush.
Shure: i need you
Shure: I need you.
Katrina: 感觉骂的很脏
Katrina: Sounds like cursing.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: ralish
Shure: Ralish.
Shure: 好的傻
Shure: Okay, silly.
Katrina: 越来越抽象了
Katrina: It's getting more abstract.
Jake:抽象确实抽象
Jake: Abstract, indeed abstract.
Katrina: 我那个香薰还蛮香的
Katrina: My aromatherapy smells pretty good.
Shure: 我让他给我占个位置
Shure: I asked him to save me a spot.
Alice:塔莎
Alice: Tasha.
Alice:早上好
Alice: Good morning.
Shure: 塔莎 早上好
Shure: Tasha, good morning.
Shure: 乌日朗
Shure: Urilang.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 跟谁说话呢
Katrina: Who are you talking to?
Shure: 跟你啊
Shure: Talking to you.
Katrina: 应该听过吧
Katrina: You must have heard it, right?
Katrina: 哎呦吆死
Katrina: Ouch, it hurts.
Jake:唉  门开了
Jake: Hey, the door opened.
Shure: 但是什么
Shure: But what?
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where are the people?
Shure: 这首歌叫啥呀
Shure: What's the name of this song?
Katrina: 流沙
Katrina: Quicksand.
Shure: 哇哦
Shure: Wow.
Shure: 谜底写在谜面上了是吗
Shure: The answer is in the question, right?
Katrina: 呃给你点小小的R&B震撼
Katrina: 定一下歌呗
Katrina: Pick a song.
Katrina: 如果要唱歌
Katrina: If you want to sing.
Katrina: 你是主力
Katrina: You're the lead.
Katrina: 嗨一点的
Katrina: Something upbeat.
Katrina: 私奔
Katrina: Elopement.
Katrina: 但我不太会唱啊
Katrina: But I don't really know how to sing it.
Katrina: 我上次去成都
Katrina: Last time I went to Chengdu.
Katrina: 感觉被咬的还是很痒那种
Katrina: I felt like I got bitten and it was still really itchy.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ahhh.
Shure: 啊里嘎多
Shure: Arigato.
Shure: 我上次去跟我女朋友去海边的时候
Shure: Last time I went to the beach with my girlfriend.
Shure: 拿着吉他
Shure: With a guitar.
Katrina: 想去海边
Shure: 然后在海边就坐沙滩上唱的私奔
Shure: And we sat on the sand and sang Elopement.
Katrina: 又来刺激我是吧
Katrina: Are you trying to provoke me again?
Katrina: 你要知道
Katrina: You should know.
Katrina: 晚上的我跟白天的我不是同一个人
Katrina: The me at night is not the same person as the me during the day.
Katrina: 斯班当时他们乐队有唱
Katrina: Their band sang Spontaneous at the time.
Katrina: 但是我不太会唱
Katrina: But I don't really know how to sing.
Shure: 很简单
Shure: It's very simple.
Katrina: 没插音箱吧怎么这么大声音
Katrina: Didn't plug in the speaker, why is it so loud?
Katrina: 唉 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Katrina: Oh, da da da da da da.
Tasha:今天是在这偷的是吧
Tasha: So you're stealing it today, right?
Jake:对外边冷了
Jake: Yeah, it's cold outside.
Shure: 唱不下去太高了
Shure: Can't continue, it's too high.
Shure: 我们可以唱一点简单
Shure: We can sing something simpler.
Shure: 你们有听过朴树的new boy吗
Shure: Have you heard of Pu Shu's "New Boy"?
Katrina: no
Katrina: No.
Shure: 就是这一首
Shure: It's this one.
Katrina: 那肯定听过 呵呵呵
Katrina: Oh, then I've definitely heard it, haha.
Jake:这朴树的
Jake: This is Pu Shu's.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 我也不知道
Katrina: I don't know.
Shure: 这哥岁数比咱都大
Shure: This guy is older than all of us.
Katrina: 我去 他给我说什么呢这是
Katrina: Oh my, what is he telling me?
Katrina: 另一个
Katrina: Another one.
Shure: 另一个
Shure: Another one.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 咦什么人
Shure: Huh, who is it?
Katrina: 什么东西啊
Katrina: What is it?
Katrina: 再给我看
Katrina: Show me again.
Katrina: 你明天早上就
Katrina: Tomorrow morning you...
Katrina: 把我们叫醒然后就坐这弹然后我们就醒了
Katrina: Wake us up and then start playing here, and we'll wake up.
Katrina: 一下可以叫醒三个
Katrina: You can wake up three people at once.
Shure: 我直接开始国际歌起来
Shure: I'll start with the "Internationale."
Jake:国际歌用吉他合适合不合适
Jake: Is the "Internationale" suitable for guitar?
Shure: 合适
Shure: Suitable.
Jake:合适
Jake: Suitable.
修硕能:能唱我们我们
Shure: Can we sing it?
Shure: 主要是看我们能不能唱
Shure: The main thing is whether we can sing it.
Jake:能唱能唱
Jake: We can sing it.
Jake:国际歌怎么了
Jake: What's wrong with the "Internationale"?
Jake:你又没唱
Jake: You didn't sing it.
Shure: 呵我知道你想说什么
Shure: Haha, I know what you want to say.
Shure: 杨老板你很危险
Shure: Jake, you're very dangerous.
Jake:你不知道
Jake: You don't know.
Shure: 我真不知道吗
Shure: Do I really not know?
Jake:你知道
Jake: You know.
Shure: 我该不该知道呢
Shure: Should I know about this?
Katrina: 唱
Katrina: Sing.
Shure: 唱什么国际歌吗
Shure: What, sing the international song?
Jake:来
Jake: Go ahead.
Shure: 我找一张谱子
Shure: I'll find a sheet.
Katrina: 所以我们在等待什么
Katrina: So what are we waiting for?
Shure: 我在等待
Shure: I'm waiting.
Shure: 塔莎戴眼镜
Shure: Tasha to put on glasses.
Jake:哈哈对啊
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:你在干哈
Jake: What are you doing?
Shure: 起来  哎呀
Shure: Get up, oh man.
Jake:你在里边吗
Jake: Are you inside?
Jake:他哪去了
Jake: Where did he go?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 你以后跟我说
Katrina: Next time, tell me.
Katrina: 要带一个那个GPS模块了
Katrina: You need to bring a GPS module.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Katrina: 受不了
Katrina: Can't handle it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈人均丢失一次
Katrina: Hahaha, everyone gets lost at least once.
Jake:我刚刚想说一个人的名字
Jake: I was just about to say someone's name.
Jake:但是不敢说
Jake: But I didn't dare.
Jake:算了
Jake: Never mind.
Shure: 在臭美什么    咦
Shure: What's with all the vanity? Eh.
Katrina: 自拍一下
Katrina: Just taking a selfie.
Shure: 给那个人发是吧好好好
Shure: Sending it to that person, right? Okay, okay.
Katrina: 不是不是
Katrina: No, no.
Shure: 不是 啊 不是 啊
Shure: No? Ah, no? Ah.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina: 不是
Katrina: No.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah, ah.
Shure: 嗯嗯嗯嗯
Shure: Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 好听
Katrina: Sounds good.
Shure: 好听
Shure: Sounds good.
Shure: 让我再看你一眼
Shure: Let me look at you again.
Shure: 从南到北
Shure: From south to north.
Katrina: 从南到北
Katrina: From south to north.
Shure: 没没没没没
Shure: No, no, no, no, no.
Shure: 你看过那个吗
Shure: Have you seen that one?
Shure: 羊头版的那个
Shure: The one with the sheep head?
Shure: 安和桥
Shure: Anhe Bridge
Katrina: 都干啥来着
Katrina: What are we doing?
Katrina: 这歌叫什么
Katrina: What's this song called?
Shure: new boy
Shure: "New Boy"
Katrina: 哎new boy
Katrina: Oh, "New Boy"
Katrina: 哦那就唱这个呗
Katrina: Oh, let's sing this one then
Shure: 这个歌还有一个同样调的另一个版本
Shure: There's another version of this song with the same tune
Shure: 叫什么
Shure: What's it called?
Shure: 曾曾经怎么说
Shure: How did it go again?
Shure: 唉我草我忘了
Shure: Ugh, damn, I forgot
Katrina: AI在注视你
Katrina: The AI is watching you
Shure: 哦叫forever young
Shure: Oh, it's called "Forever Young"
Shure: 就是一样的调
Shure: It's the same tune
Shure: 但是它的词儿不一样那个是
Shure: But the lyrics are different, that one is...
Katrina: 你带手套干嘛
Katrina: Why are you wearing gloves?
Jake:我在揉面
Jake: I'm kneading dough
Katrina: 你在揉面
Katrina: You're kneading dough
Jake:对你们把曲子定了吧
Jake: Yeah, you guys finalize the song
Jake:你们仨把曲子定了吧
Jake: You three finalize the song
Katrina: 所以说我把开会流程变成我们三个了
Katrina: So, I turned the meeting process into the three of us
Jake:我把这
Jake: I'll just...
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Shure: 然后就是把曲子定一下就好
Shure: So, just finalize the song
Jake:曲子定一下
Jake: Finalize the song
Katrina: 谁会唱歌
Katrina: Who can sing?
Jake:明天明天安排
Jake: Tomorrow, we'll arrange it tomorrow
Katrina: 柯欣你唱吗
Katrina: Kexin, will you sing?
Jake:明明天明天探探走一遍明
Jake: Yes, tomorrow we'll go through it
Katrina: 咱搞一个合唱呗就不跳舞了
Katrina: Let's do a chorus, no dancing
Alice:我
Alice: I'll
Jake:对明天探探和
Jake: Yeah, we'll go through it tomorrow and...
Jake:就是其实明天就是彩排
Jake: Actually, tomorrow is just a rehearsal
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Jake:和收视方面
Jake: And for the show
Katrina: 唱呗不然就我们两个
Katrina: Let's sing, otherwise it's just the two of us
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Shure: 我们俩唱
Shure: We'll sing
Katrina: 多尴尬啊
Katrina: How awkward
Shure: 唱素颜 哈哈哈
Shure: We'll sing "Bare-faced", haha
Katrina: 我们两个直接唱破音
Katrina: We'll just sing off-key, haha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:唱对
Jake: Sing it right
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay
Katrina: 哎素颜很适合
Katrina: Hey, no makeup suits you
Katrina: 吉他那个耶
Katrina: With the guitar, yeah
Shure: 好像是
Shure: Seems like it
Jake:那你们聊聊
Jake: You guys chat
Jake:然后彩排也聊一聊
Jake: And talk during rehearsal too
Katrina: 搞个节目
Katrina: Let's put on a show
Katrina: 我感觉唱歌比唱歌可以唱个俩
Katrina: I feel like singing is better than singing two songs
Jake:我我们揉完应该就上来了
Jake: We should be done massaging soon
Jake:也揉个20分钟吧
Jake: Probably another 20 minutes
Katrina: 唱个大家都会的国歌
Katrina: Let's sing a national anthem everyone knows
Shure: 你你怎么这么疯呢
Shure: Why are you so crazy?
Katrina: 我我是火象星座
Katrina: I am a fire sign
Shure: 你火象星座你也不会违
Shure: Even if you're a fire sign, you can't break the law